uh my name is Nuri I'm going to be
talking about designing a good schema uh
to get better results
um I've been a developer to start with
Delta lot with back end our database or
data structures been doing a lot of data
migrations lately been doing a lot of
c-sharp in my career
also other programming languages python
JavaScript stuff like that
and since I've been around I figured I
put the stock together just to kind of
share my experience about what worked
short term what worked longer term and
this is really about trying to optimize
for longer term so if I break down the
slide into what I'm really looking at
the use case scenario I'm kind of
envisioning here is that as a developer
I want a good schema that I won't regret
later
and we've all been there or maybe
haven't
um that we designed something we thought
it's great we thought it's quick we
thought we fulfilled everything just to
find out that after delivering the first
iteration or the first iteration into
test or living with it for a year or
five uh you discover all of these things
that all of these decisions that seemed
right at the time and turned out not to
be optimal
so breaking it down a little more we
have to ask ourselves well good scheme
assam's color qualifying what is the
word good like what do I mean by that
okay that's a fair question so
the fitness criteria I'm looking for I
need to stay in this song because
otherwise I'm walking off camera okay
it's here so the fitness criteria I'm
looking for are roughly that the schema
really wants to solve a business problem
um
so what would be not a business problem
like making my boss happy would not be a
business problem if it serves a customer
yes it's a big it's a business problem
but if it doesn't it really doesn't
belong in the things I need to solve
so you gotta watch out for requirement
creeps that tell you how to do things
that has nothing to do with the real
business problem you're solving and
within what you're solving for the real
business you want to make sure that it
doesn't uh scope creep into things that
are not in the real world that are
internal technical things that can creep
in and pressure you to make schema
decisions based on that that don't
belong to solving so it's the size of
the actual word that I care about and
the things that serve that fit in the
things that don't maybe a little less so
and the schema should be easy to reason
with right note the future self I need
to read this later I need to communicate
this with a team I need everybody to be
on the same page and understand it I
don't want something so convoluted that
is so difficult to use
one example of that has anybody heard of
eav entity attribute value
type schemas one over there
um
if we have time I can go into this big
anti-pattern for for any kind of medium
to large scale it's a way to represent
things in a very flexible way in
databases schemas that were designed to
be rigid and well defined
the disaster with that is that querying
this thing in any kind of way is is just
kind of horrific and convoluted and very
difficult to reason with
and finally I wanted to be change
tolerant so in the interest of future
self I want to be able to evolve this as
my product evolves as our business case
evolves with a minimal set of impact
and I'm saying model
but we got to talk about this for a
second because that's a design thing
model versus schema so in the title I
put schema and schema is very specific
model the real world is out there it's
well we're in it right we're right here
and this is the domain this is the area
in which we talk about models
so I can model a person I can look at
real world things about a person their
height uh how they're dressed uh their
hair color if they have any uh things
like that
that was a joke sorry okay
thank you
and then in the database world when
we're talking about stuff we're talking
about schema we're talking really about
the structures of how the data is
actually stored and that dictates how it
would be processed and the most
important thing is the design so the
design is moving from the world the real
world the model into the schema
a model represents the
uh real world
did you notice it looks like a smiley I
don't know I kind of liked it uh a model
represents the real world uh so the
model is looking at a person looking at
properties that I can see looking at a I
don't know an oil rig a pipe a whatever
it is we represent a catalog item is a
product right so catalog item belongs
into this idea that we have some kind of
catalog maybe it's a real printable
catalog and there's items that I show in
the brochure and now I show it in the
web but that's representative of the
real world I pick out things that are
observable about the thing I'm trying to
represent so a catalog item has a name
and I give it a name it has some
measurements things like that and it's
the stuff I care about for business
so if I care about its weight then it's
in my model and if I don't care about
its weight it's not in my model as
simple as that
schema on their other hand schema
implements the model so once we came up
with what we care about from the
business perspective from The Real World
then we design we can move into schema
land and schema land is where we get to
speak a different language
because when I say an item has a weight
there is no weight inside computer
language
there's numbers I can pick the right
number for it or the right
representation for whatever I'm trying
to do so I can say oh a weight is just a
decimal representation of the weight in
kilograms or in grams or in pounds or
stone or whatever I want
but there is no weight inside SQL SQL is
its own language
so really we're going to start
translating things that in the real
world were expressed in all of the terms
we know in our own language of what we
speak speaking language and translating
it into schema in some way
and it describes an entity graph
in that when we have things and I have
an item and I have a catalog that's a
graph that's a representation of
relationships between different things a
catalog item to a catalog in invoice of
you know a piece of paper that details
you know the customer and the items they
have in their shopping cart or stuff
like that their prices the totals all of
these kind of things so all of these
things are relationships between things
and
um I just say this is a graph this is a
a representation of nodes with
connections between them
it can describe
constraints on values so that's a domain
of schema so when I say hey I have
countries in the real world that's in my
model
in SQL there is no country's data type
right there's a stringy data type
there's a numeric data type there's all
kinds of things I can say okay well you
know I'll store it in a chart too
because I have ISO two letter codes for
all countries that would be called a
domain so it's a type meaning car Char
whatever you want and it has
restrictions on what values it has it
doesn't have to be restriction it could
be looked as allow us but in any case
I'm describing that when I store this
stuff it better be in that domain
and some databases actually support this
notion and allow you to declare a domain
it's it's a it's a pretty pretty rare to
see that people really use domain more
likely they're using what's called
domain tables which is just creating a
table and saying ah this table is the
universe of all values that could be
ever used for a country
and
your mileage may vary I'm not talking
about specific database implementation
here so
um you know you may find that you want
to use domains you may find that you
want to use the more generic
implementation of domain tables to
restrict which values can go in
and finally the schema layout will
actually impact your performance and
this is where I recommend to not come to
my talk but go and hit the books talk to
your dbas uh go to courses study on your
own read the manual however you find a
way to learn more about the
implementation the engine itself how it
works the better your performance will
be because as it turns out your schema
could be
implemented you can Define tables with
partitions you can define various
indexing strategies clustered indexes
all kinds of things that will
vastly improve your performance or
totally kill it depending on what
choices you make so this is where beyond
the concept of schema and just saying
using generic ddl data definition
language to describe my tables and my
stuff you can go in and use the
optimization that each engine provides
for you in order to create say a
partition table in order to map
partitions to files files groups things
like that those kind of things if you
get deep into it can help you a lot
and those tend to fold in a lot more
knowledge of not just the model but how
your use case is going to lay out on
that meaning how often are you going to
access things at what rate how much data
you expect things like that
and the main thing is I don't want to
regret it right I don't want to make
things that decisions today that I will
regret tomorrow so the question is what
will I regret tomorrow I can tell you a
few things I regretted one is things
were way too complicated too complicated
I I did the eav model once regretted it
wholeheartedly it's a complex way to
represent flexible objects and
relational databases are just not built
for that so every query and everything
we wanted to do it was an uphill battle
downtime when changes were too vast when
I needed to make a change and it
required me to take the database offline
and therefore the applications I talk to
it offline that's very painful
and just lots of work if the changes are
possible but just require a ton of work
that's big investment that's more
planning that's more involvement of more
people that's harder to roll into
production so those are all regrettable
decisions
so in terms of work
I kind of put together this thing and um
it it it's DB engine specific
but I think it's worth staring at for a
little bit
um I tried to say well
how do we break down what is the impact
of change if I want to change something
what does it involve
so in terms of ddl and we're talking
about the data definition language how
my tables are declared what do I declare
I declare that there is a table or there
isn't
right create a table okay that's cheap
just create a new table nobody used it
before what's my dependencies another
just about zero right I can do that all
day
but if I drop a table I gotta ask myself
hey was the stable involved with anybody
else was it part of a graph with other
things in which case you know there may
be a little more impact or high impact
depending on how uh how interconnected
how many foreign Keys it has to other
things
so dropping a table and creating a table
not the same and dropping a table that
has strings and tentacles to other stuff
more expensive
adding a column with a null value
generally considered a zero cost
operation populating it with values can
take a little more
huge huge tables even more but still
it's within the realm of kinda easy
right
but if this was involved with other key
constraints if the column was involved
in some constraints then we have to take
more care it's not a zero time operation
on large tables when you manipulate
columns that participate in foreign key
that's where your complexity suddenly
starts that's where interconnectivity
shows up and then you may have cascading
updates in other places so that costs
more
um talking about dropping column kind of
similar to dropping a table that has
that column because it all has to do
with these interconnected with this
graph of objects that interact with each
other
and finally changing a column type
it kind of depends if your column types
become
um
if if you had a numeric that was too
narrow and you widened it you're really
more accommodating if you're taking a
type and changing it completely it was
string and now it's an INT anybody that
treated it before a string and wanted to
parse it now has to worry about it so
that's a more sweeping change
um and then if you're narrowing
something if you're taking something
that was open and making it more
restrictive
then again you have to worry about
everybody that was using it making sure
their math isn't harmed making sure your
data didn't lose Precision without you
knowing and intending to do that
so it's kind of good I think to map
the impact of the changes I anticipate
or the changes I might experience as a
result of changing constraints to map it
mentally to like what's the cost of this
change
and if you start with that then when
you're designing you say okay I'm doing
this decision
now what if I had to change it what
changes can happen to it and based on
that I can try to project well is it
advisable to do today
So based on what I just said I would
start with
seven ish kind of areas that I marked as
uh errors or things to know or things to
do that might make your life better or
pick data types
opaque data types are data types that
don't represent a single thing or don't
represent anything for the database
itself
a composed string
can be an opaque data type
if I have
full name as a field in my database
or a column in my database I should say
and I always treat it as just full name
my database is just for label printing I
put in the name it's part of the address
is full name it's just a thing that
appears on the line I never care if it's
Nuri Halperin or Bob Smith or Jane J
Smith or whatever it is doesn't matter
but it becomes an opaque data type if in
my business requirements I need to then
go and sort it by last name
because the database has no idea that
within this string
there's some spaces and they mean
something and then that the last part of
it is actually the last name
and sometimes last names are multi-word
last names so actually counting and
going to the last is not going to work
and the database has no idea about it
right the database is just varchar and
varchar right as programmers we think
string but same thing the database even
in string it's opaque because it has
multiple parts
so doing that
messes you up later it's better if you
know that there are constituents to a
thing to break it apart into its
constituents
blob for the same reason a blob is
something that maybe doesn't have
delimiters naturally in it or that they
are not even attainable within the SQL
language a byte string would be
a good example for that where
um you know it's just a sequence of
bytes and sure in programming I know how
to scroll in and use protobufs and hop
into the right byte to extract the field
from it but as far as the database is
concerned it's a blob
image data jpegs inside the database
I I never not regretted putting binary
data in the database like there's an app
for that it's called the file system
it's called buckets
store the pointer
those are things for those are
infrastructure for these things in the
database keep things that are relational
that are property that are processable
processible with logical operators
I can't say image one greater than image
image two makes no sense I can't scroll
in there and even tell you if it's an
exif A J fifth or a gif or a gif can't
say any of that just don't know
and Json and XML suffer some from some
stuff that is very similar except as
humans we can say oh what do you mean I
understand these delimiters
but the database doesn't so don't do
that
incorrect data types you know dates as
strings is the most often seen one in my
experience it's just using the database
uh to store seemingly flexible data type
or just shuttling it from the front end
and having no marshalling so I can show
it as a string again the database
doesn't know how to compare it correctly
at best you will do an ISO
representation that is canonical and you
can do comparisons of greater less than
but then you'll have to break it apart
look at constituent of the time time
zone offset things like that
ugly stuff there is a database data type
for that in the database knows how to do
things like extract the time zone the
minute the second the whatever from
proper date types so use the proper date
time
and finally non-domain values it's not
something you do in your ddl so much but
if in your column you're going to shove
some random value that is not from your
domain
like you have all country codes and then
you represent Country Code Zero for all
of those that you don't know the country
code
that's wrong and putting null is also
not something from the domain
null
is it a type is it a value it's not a
value it's a type right and it doesn't
belong to the country codes there is no
country in the world that is null
right so it's a non-domain value and
non-domain values mean that the database
doesn't know that it doesn't belong
there so all comparisons are going to
run against it as if it's just part of
the domain but in fact it isn't and you
will have to write extra logic to handle
it everywhere
so don't store values that don't belong
to the domain that you intended
how do we fix OPEC data types I created
a I think I talked about
the OPEC data type issues
um
that SQL language is not made to do it
there's limited support and opaque data
types and non-domain values are are hard
to deal with and just inject a lot of
logic and later on you'll have to undo
that or change it or handle it
everywhere it just kind of spiders
throughout your organization so how to
fix it
it's pretty simple it looks cunningly
like
denormalization templates uh except I
don't love the word denormalization
um
you start with a value
you have in your domain something you
need to represent it you stare at it and
you ask yourself is it atomic is it
Atomic yes I can map it directly to a
SQL data type
if it's so that's the top branch on the
train then I've won let's see if pointer
technology works here
so you go in here is it Atomic yes great
good you just encode it as a SQL native
type and you've won you come in and it's
not atomic
and now the question is what's it what
is its non-atomicity
is it because it's actually a set of
properties like you took a dictionary
and tried to shove it into Json
if you did that then this is a key value
really it's this Branch right here
and each key really wants to be a column
the way to represent things in a SQL
database is assigning a column with a
proper data type nanopic
so you take each one of the keys you
turn it into a column name and you stare
at the value
but you're not done because that value
in itself
you have to look at it and ask yourself
again is it Atomic yes okay I've won I'm
done with my column no it's not okay
well ask yourself again is it a
dictionary with keys and values in which
case you want to break it or is it a
sequence of items
maybe you have an array masquerading as
XML or something like that
or maybe you have a train of values
represented by some buffer or something
like that and they are actually an array
or a set of things
so then the answer there is well if it's
a set of things since columns in SQL
better be Atomic that means I need a
different table
so it's going to become a column in
another table with a reference back to
the parent table
so that's my algorithm there
make sense
any questions on that
okay
which brings us to
air 2. I see a lot
multi-entity table
multi-entity table is a generalized
table
it's a table that wants to store kind of
the parent or the base
and also all its children in one row
and the thing about it
is that you can see it when you see rows
which have either pattern or unpatterned
columns that are always null for some
rows and not null for others
and they interleave with rows that are
null for others but not for some
okay it's hard to say it in English
let's look at an example
here we have a table of a catalog item
a catalog item in my catalog has a SKU
SKU
something a code that represents that in
my company
a name every catalog item it's a shirt
it's pants it's something
and it has numeric size and letter size
and if I looked at values for this table
I probably would see that I have you
know School ABC T-shirt size m
and size M will have numeric size as
sorry letter size populated in numeric
size null
versus I'll have you know pants with
size 32 and
um then I'll have the letter size null
and the name so I can kind of look at it
and see okay well the generalization
here is that I have a table and there's
a generality that all items have a
school and a name
but then I have some properties some
columns that are valid for some stuff
but not other and that's because I have
products that are inherently different
in the real world in the real world I
find a shirt and it has an m on the back
or I have a shirt or a top that has a
size numeric on the back and they're
kind of different they're cut different
they're manufactured different they're
aimed at different people
so they are really different
but I made them live together in one
table
so the way to kind of fix this
is to say well I have a catalog item I
still want to be generic there could be
category catalog items corresponding to
different uh things in the real world
but then I have
my numeric size catalog items and I
shortened the name of the table here but
those are numeric sized things
and they have a numeric size
and then I have a letter size
and that lives in a different table
so I'm not going to have null in the
letter size ever
and catalog item that happened to be
letter sized will have a relationship to
the stable and if I join it it will come
out not null and vice versa and if I
ever wanted a view that joined both of
them or all three tables then I would
have a flat thing but I will have it in
different columns and I will know what
to expect because I did this
right I know very easily that this is
um an item that has a letter size
because it will have a school and a
school for letter size dot school and a
letter as letter size dot letter size
coming back in my joined uh expression
to show me what it is so the database
doesn't have to think hard if it was
more like it was on the left I will need
to expose logic
um everywhere to tell if this row
happens to be
wanting to represent things in one way
or another or I will have to package it
as an OPEC data type that's where people
do type as string and just says oh I'll
just do size and it'll be a VAR binary
and let the application worry about it
well great but then what if you want to
sort Shirts by size
well you know your size 30 40 will sort
correctly Maybe
or maybe it looks graphically and
incorrectly and surely you know
SML XL double XL all of those uh extra
small will sort weirdly
so it's just not good for anyone really
to to do OPEC or to have these nulls
either way kind of messes you up
onwards
um
this one is about abnormal form which
means I failed to uh do my process for
storing things atomically and in their
proper tables
so I have my table enrollment here
and enrollment in my university has
people with a first name and a last name
and I place uh
I have a placeholder for the scores for
the exams uh and uh you know the course
belongs to a certain major no it's not
the course it's the professor and
there's a course itself what the course
code is and a teacher and assistant and
stuff like that so A bunch of things
smell here let's kind of go through them
the first thing is I'm limited to the
number of exams that can occur in a
semester or a quarter or whatever system
right because I chose to Pivot this and
just put the exams right there so where
should it have been
a different table that's right
and then if exam final exam hasn't
occurred yet there will be no row it's
not like I have a placeholder because I
know I have it it just doesn't exist at
this point
um in this I will have nulls often
because I fixed the columns which means
that as time goes by I will start
filling in the exam scores and if
somebody missed an exam it will forever
be no
also some of my courses uh just have a
teacher a professor some of them have a
teaching assistant but that means that
rose that there is no teacher assistant
forever will have null in there so we
talked about that that's silly
we have a fixed faculty assignment which
means for extremely uh large classes I
might not be able to accommodate another
ta and other teacher assistance
um I might be duplicating data when I
see these kind of things there's usually
another table which represents the
teacher elsewhere so instead of using
reference properly to just say well
here's a teacher go join if you need
their name or whatever the primary key
was
um
that that is probably duplicating data
which means at some point There's issues
of maintaining consistency between this
table and the other one
um and you're trying to predict the
future you're trying to predict that
this you know
student will actually complete the
course
you're trying to predict that you will
need to accommodate teachers assistance
you're trying to do all kinds of things
all kinds of assumptions that may not
actually Bear in reality
so the effects of that
you will have sparse columns that's the
ones with nulls that may forever be null
may just populate over time it can
decrease your flexibility in case I
wanted to play with how many Tas and
things happen
it may negate the join engine the engine
join optimizations where
um
I have um the the query optimizers know
how to look at the statistics of indexes
and see which query it should do first
if I joined you know all of my students
into courses it knows which one has more
rows and knows how to do it faster if it
gets right statistics but when you have
null columns it doesn't
it just has to kind of guess as to which
of the values in the index you're going
to hit and it's difficult for it to do
without actually scanning the index
and as a result you will have indexes
that need to contain references to all
of
um the values in the columns so even if
you have nulls some engines will still
keep index keys on it or reference to
rows with the null value and that
increases the overall index size
whereas if it was in a side table and
there's only you know 10 Tas in the
whole school well the index size will be
10 entries
and depending on your engine locks and
things like that will also creep up so
as you update tables that are
multi-entity or that are of abnormal
form
you will find that right lock
contentions at a higher level like at
the table instead of just Roblox will
start creeping up because everything you
write is into the table whereas if you
just wanted to add a teacher's assistant
in a teacher's assistant table you're
locking there so now you made all the
locks kind of
compete in this table space
so that's about it and the queries
complex Point uh is is kind of similar
here and the multi-ended table which is
um
that queries need to bifurcate them I
querying here because I'm trying to hit
the teacher and what they teach or the
student or something and they need to
deal with the null ability of certain
fields and say is this person not doing
this exam or the exam hasn't passed yet
we don't know
the exam date hasn't arrived yet sorry
so logic will creep in and be spread
everywhere
this is my attempt at humor
thank you thank you for your grace on
this
um let's talk keys let's talk references
um so in the world of keys
there's what's called a natural key and
a natural key is something that I can
see in the real world
so a natural key whatever I observe in
the outside world in my model
it exists in the model then it could be
natural if it doesn't exist in a model
it is probably not natural
now natural doesn't mean
that it's always non-assigned so if I
have an agency that issued the iso
two-letter code
effectively it's a natural key of
countries
because it's part of a real business
world it's something that an authority
took over and it might be an authority
of mine right I may be Twitter and I may
be issuing or allowing for user names or
handles or whatever system we have and
that becomes a natural key because I
manage it it's a thing so if it's for if
it's a thing then it still kind of
belongs in the natural key part of
things most importantly it's meaningful
and then it's part of the model
it exists outside of my database
artificial keys
are meaningful
they're known
in the real world but they're kind of
foreign to The Entity itself so
countries in a domain of country in if I
my entity was country that's a natural
key but if it's me and my citizenship
my citizenship is not me
I am a person I'm attached to a
citizenship it's foreign to the me It's
associated it's still it's artificial
but it's still observable in some way
shape or form associated in the real
world
and now we go a little further in the
rabbit hole don't slip and fall like the
guy in the icon we have exposed locators
and exposed locators are things that are
in the database but not in the real
world
so those are primary keys
let's say something that's a row ID an
exposed row ID so like an identity
column uuid that I assigned as a primary
key as something a sequence those are
things that are meaningful only to the
database engine
but I can't go up to a person and say oh
year one two three four yeah yeah
like there's no I like Pat him down
there's no one two three four anywhere
in the pockets there's just doesn't
exist it's just an artifact of the
database
which means a lot of times it's also an
artifact of that database instance like
on that machine it's not everywhere
which means I will have drift in other
environments and things like that if I
try to replicate I might have collisions
if it was generated by two different uh
systems things like that
and those are exposed locators the
exposed part here is that it's visible
meaning I can somehow interact with it
from my program this is a worse class
which is the real surrogate key
and these are ones that are not exposed
so as you can imagine internally
databases have identifiers for the
blocks or for the row or things like
that that are not even exposed to the
programmers
and some systems kind of let you use
them by using special functions saying
hey which version of this row do you
have and it will give you a long ugly
number and says this is you know storage
related
so that's very crusty stuff don't use
that ever for uh primary keys
so using meaningless Keys is the error
here if you're using meaningless Keys
things that don't participate in the
real world
either either being artificial or being
just not part of the real world not
natural in any way shape or form
you are really
um
making everything more complicated
um the number of joins you'll need to do
let's say I have country ID 3 on my UI I
can't say what this country ID is
and Dora Angola I I forget but you know
I I don't know right
if I ever want the country code or if I
ever want its name I would have to join
to another table in order to get it if
you use natural keys
and my natural key say is this iso2
letter code or the name of the country
or ISO 3 then it's always there in my
column already it already answers this
question and if I wanted to filter I
could filter through this yes sir
yeah so there will be an impact in the
impact on the change of the natural key
will be judged by how we look at the
impact of change so would that be a type
change
no it would be a domain change right it
would be a
change in the value Universe of that
domain and in case that it's additive
it's kind of similar to
just adding a column that nobody used
before and in case it's a change because
it's primary key I think the gentleman
is hinting at the fact that primary Keys
need a property of immutability or rare
changiness and that would have cascading
effect which means it's harder yeah but
harder does not mean
don't ever do it harder means what is my
main use case scenario for 99 of the
time right
um yeah so good point and I will judge
it by the effort the pain it will cause
me in the future the thing is
I always have to join always always
always always
when I use a circuit key or exposed
identifier
I always have to do it so it's permeated
through the whole thing
and I said oh well they're using
identity column that's fine right but
everywhere in my joins everywhere join
join join join join join and I'm like oh
that's okay like oh my God there's a new
ISO letter code or a country split
happens
it's like happens once once in five
years
it's not everywhere yeah it affects a
lot of things but
so
where where am I going to have more pain
that's kind of my question
I'll take more questions later let me um
continue on here
um so it increases the number of joint
tables great example by the way
increases the number of indexes because
now because I have joins every foreign
key will need an index on the
referencing table
so it will increase that increase the
number of objects because I will need
that index I will need that extra table
it may be sometimes I can have a domain
represented already there
so what if country code is used for
addresses and used for citizenships
do I need another table to just say oh
my God these are country codes I better
have a table for country codes
or can I use a constraint that says hey
in this country we only allow this array
of items and use a check constraint or
use something else another mechanism to
enforce that domain and not use domain
tables it's also possible
um the clustering indexing efficiency
has to do with
with the exact engine so SQL server has
this thing called the clustered index
other databases don't quite do it this
way so uh your mileage may vary there uh
what would happen is when you're issuing
sequences uh for the primary key when
you're writing each right by definition
is just one number higher which means
you kind of right into the table at the
end of the table and if you're updating
it frequently that creates a hotspot
um
other Technologies might have other
Effects by this so
um it kind of this is a place where you
want to really learn about your specific
database and how these things behave
speaking of which that's the next slide
is sequential primary key auto-generated
keys and sequences are surrogate Keys
sequences are not meaningful in the uh
real world they're just invented things
that I somehow glued to my object and
because of that they suffer all of the
things we already discussed they're hard
to migrate among systems so that
happened to me a lot where on day one
you're in developer land on week two
you're in production yeah we
threw things in production after two
weeks
um
and then you know on year three we want
to simulate all the real problems we
have in production so we asked the ddbas
hey bring us back all the data from
production into uat or some area in
order for us to simulate and run our
software on real data because our
backend system as developers don't have
all this data in some of the conditions
and things we want to check is on a
variety of real world data
but then we kind of have to keep
resetting everything according to
production sanitize things like that
because there's collision with those
keys and when you have more than one
system then these keys that are
meaningless migrate into other systems
and they're not in sync anymore
because this you know person's country
ID says oh you know give me a list of
this country ID and another system and
the other system that country ID has
already changed because it's meaningless
it now collides with a different value a
different row altogether
so it's harder to keep in sync
um hotspot risks we spoke about and the
drift among environments can cause a lot
of
a lot of havoc on its own also
discourages schema migration so that
will come up in an later slide but I'll
talk a little bit about schema
migrations
so sequential primary keys are
essentially exposed locators
most people don't talk about the
difference between exposed locators and
surrogate keys so we'll call it circuit
key to adhere with the world
so what I want from a primary key I want
it to be
familiar I want it to be something that
somebody knowing the domain will say oh
yeah I get this
right an email address a username fine
sometimes a number is okay if that
number means something maybe it's your
ID number national ID something like
that it's okay
you want it to be stable
as a gentleman stated
um if things change what then
Well yeah if things change we'll need to
make changes the question is how rare is
it so when we say it's stable we don't
mean immutable forever we mean mostly
immunable
uh so mostly immunable means that
sometimes it will change on their very
rare condition
and then we'll have to deal with it most
relational databases also a lot of the
nosql databases
require you to keep to require not
require impose that the primary key is
immutable
those that support transactions allow
you to change that value under a cover
of a transaction
which means you basically delete the old
row insert a new row in its place with a
change value under one transaction cover
the operation can be long running if
there's a lot of dependencies or pretty
short but in any event we expect that it
is rare
so meaningful uh rarely changes
and convenient it's simple and compact
so don't ask me about how to represent
people because it's a first name first
name last name middle oh there's a
collision what else can I do can I Pat
people down do I put their DNA sequence
into the ID no that's a tougher one to
answer but typically it comes with
something I'm making a system for the
immigration services okay it has to do
with IDs it has to do with some other
external IDs that I can attach to it and
make it as something right or I make my
own I say hey your email address is you
I don't care what your name is your
email address is you and you are the
recipient of all of those change
passwords so this is you for all
intensive purposes
or a username or something like that and
then we don't want it to be too many
elements we want it to be somewhat
compact so it's convenient we want it
simple
so we don't have to deal with a lot of
logic to have multiple you know 10
column primary Keys kind of gnarly and
it appears again and again and again in
all your queries so we want it as simple
as possible
and now we switch abruptly to not
talking about the database so much but
talking about development and
development practices
and this is where orm comes into play
and
as a developer I love orm
I love the orm idea the first time I saw
it
um then I went to production
so the trouble with orm is that tables
are not classes
tables are the language that proprietary
SQL language that describes the schema
which has to do with the data layout
which the engines are then optimized to
deal with an answer for
but they're not classes
in a class I don't have pointers to
other things like foreign Keys it's just
a class has properties it's all in
memory as some contiguous something
typically
and the database is not the repo pattern
and orms kind of encourage the repo
pattern which is like oh I have an
entity like invoices
okay well that's my class invoice and
the class has an array of invoice items
each one has a school and a quantity
maybe I copy in the title of the name or
something who cares and it also has a
customer
which is a reference to you know
something so what the orm will happily
do is just go and spider all of the
tables because
you know School items items are many for
one invoice I have a table and I have a
relationship and it will Traverse it and
do the whole thing and and it will
produce just gnarly uh queries in order
to do this and then when I say okay on
top of this a repo essentially what I'm
saying is suck up all of this data into
memory and let me in memory iterate it
as if it's some kind of loop well that
will be either chatty like get me the
next one the next one the next one with
all the joins or it will be chunky like
load everything into memory and let me
do it into memory in memory either one
of those is a heavy operation
and the database engine can't really
help you so it just gets gnarly's
queries executes them on your behalf and
tries to deserialize everything and then
the cost of serializing is also present
deserializing from the database
so I don't like the database repo uh
kind of mentality uh database is a repo
mentality that is imposed through using
an orm
you have a diminished benefit from the
orm in my experience in that you start
with you know oh Entity framework oh
forward generated schema or backwards
generator schema my DBA did a good job
let me just suck it in generate classes
either way this is great for week one
hey Nuri did you manage to start the
project oh yeah I have working code
now put it in production and for the
next five years you're gonna fight it
all of those decisions you have a static
class not a static you have a class that
got declared if you want to make any
changes it has cascading impact into the
database
because now you have to forward generate
tables and you have to do migrations
according to how the orm side vice versa
also same thing changes in the database
now you have to change the classes that
are essentially the dto of your database
right they are classes representing the
schema and it's not exactly the class
you wanted it's a class that got derived
because the orm said so
that's not how I like to live my life
you'll have concurrency issues because
the repo model the repo mentality makes
you think of the invoice as a single
thing but then if you want to change the
invoice you're not thinking about just
changing the element
and if you change just a line item and
change the quantity
the object that was in memory that was
the whole invoice and mapped to a class
that you have at your disposal are not
in sync
so you have to do things like
concurrency tracking change tracking
doing all kinds of back and forth to see
if it changed before you write it all
kinds of stuff like that which would not
be necessary if you went directly
and finally
um it's once established not finally I
kind of mentioned it once you establish
the entity to class mapping it's it's
kind of costly to change it and it's
kind of opaque to change it you make
these changes and you know a lot of
things happen in the background and
chasing it everywhere becomes difficult
so Nuri do you really think RMS have no
place well now I'm a consultant of
course it depends
so the things I say maybe orms are
helpful
are in the arena of
connection management
it brings you some benefit that you
don't have to do it on your own hide
some connection pools or contains a
connection pooling and kind of instant
Singleton instance that you can deal
with or multiple injectable items that
map to the same underlying
infrastructure not the lousiest idea
maybe that's a useful thing it does the
codec work of mapping between the
tabular data format that came from The
Wire into SQL types and into c-sharp
types I like that that that's a good
thing right if I could get a bunch of
stuff a bunch of tables and
automatically marry them to my um
marry them to my to my classes I I kind
of like this but I really don't like the
command marshalling the fact that I have
to go through the orm just to call
stored procedures functions things like
that and personally it just makes no
sense to me you could use the driver the
driver actually does it not the orm so
use the driver directly the abstractions
it provides such as repo patterns and
stuff like that
seem nice but
you know after week two I usually just
fight against the orm instead of
enjoying it so that tells me it's not
that useful
and change detection concurrency uh
handling and all of that I just that
that is something that I really uh
resent every time I encounter it's just
not not fun
and then the last one
uh we'll talk about here number seven uh
is ad hoc ddl so the notion of uh going
and just adding a column by hand
uh that you know I've seen dbas do this
I've seen various degrees of of
responsibility around it the problem
with manual changes to ddl or creation
is that it's not very repeatable or not
reliably repeatable you can't automate
this you can't play this again in every
environment and you can't sometimes tell
what happened if you don't have a good
record of who made the action who
changed things how you're going to know
when Trouble Comes how come it was
working yesterday and not working today
like what is the change when did it
happen who did it for what purpose we
don't know any of this and the foregone
conclusion is well you know use
migration script
so you can use uh you know Flyway liquid
base whatever your system supports or
you love using uh if you're not using
any of those please read up and uh look
at it the nice thing about migration
scripts is you store them as files
the Frameworks themselves let you just
play it you can play it on demand many
of them support the notion of rollback
so if you made a mistake you can revert
having it in automation CI CD I'm sure
we've all talked about in the last 10
years so this is what enables you to do
CI CD with databases highly recommended
um
and that's about it
so my advice in summary is all just use
natural keys to the degree possible use
the database how it was intended to be
used which is store Atomic values
normalized to the degree possible
concise data types for what you're
trying to represent and not wishy-washy
things like Json and XML shoved in a
relational database
come to my later if you want to
talk about documents my mom will talk
later
orms not my favorite at all
and if you've ever had to fight your orm
and go below it and just hand it a
statement you know that the orm didn't
help you you know it
inside right
okay
so that is it I'll take questions we
have a couple minutes or we don't have
minutes
okay
I can't use natural Keys like a
meaningful Keys would you recommend
using minions so the question is and uh
don't feel obligated to sit down it's
past time here
um
in the case of natural if natural keys
don't work would I recommend using a
non-natural key so synthetic yes
uh exposed identifier or surrogate
surrogate
it's almost impossible to use pure
surrogate but
um I I would recommend against it in
many all cases in other words Invent
Yourself if if nobody else if there's no
Authority that lets you identify
something then you are the authority and
if you are the authority maybe own up to
it and become the authority on that like
that is what a school is Right a stop
stock keeping unit no other manufacturer
could tell me what the item number is
because their item numbers are private
to them I'm the big shop that sells from
many manufacturers and they could
Collide so I assigned it a stock keeping
unit which is a number on the Shelf of
how I keep it so I became the authority
to that otherwise I would have to say
galvanized screw you know M3
and I would not be able to distinguish
it so how do I distinguish disambiguate
it with a school that's completely
synthetic or with a dash manufacturer
number or with a something I become the
Authority for that and I store it
okay uh thank you so much
um
enjoy the rest of them